five years ago I thought I lost you  forever  there is no curse that could ever tell  me away from you will you marry me yes  [Music]  mistress I have a little bit of news  don't ruin my morning  there have asked me to marry him no I  wasn't really asking nor was I love  doesn't always end well beasty trust me  let us prove you wrong you have done an  admirable job going against your own  nature to raise this child but now she  will finally get the love of a real  mother tonight I consider Aurora  my there will be no wedding  what have you done  Aurora  Maleficent is a threat to everyone we'll  do our best to protect hell  one can never be too careful  you  you do not know me  tell me what happened there was another  creature  you've spent years caring for a shoe  now it's time to care for your own  [Music]  [Applause]